hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
minecraft fried viele haben ihm gesagt
hey luca da kommt noch gar nicht richtig
weihnachts feeling auf deswegen habe ich
mir gedacht schlips und ich habe mir
auch gedacht schlips und jetzt habt ihr
einerseits megacoolen face cam rahmen
und unter anderem auch schnee also ich
hab das jetzt hingekriegt hat mich zwei
stunden angesetzt dass ich es einfach
mal schaffe irgendwie schnee zu
animieren in photoshop das hat mir aber
naja ich mach das natürlich unglaublich
gerne und ich finde jetzt auch irgendwie
ich glaube die stimmung ist jetzt ein
bisschen besser und zwar hab ich jetzt
sehr schnell hier drin und face kamera
haben das eigentlich ganz cool und
letztes mal habe ich eigentlich auch
gesagt ja die folgen sollen so circa
sieben bis zehn minuten lang werden die
folge wird einfach irgendwo 23 minuten
lang aber das wird sich jetzt natürlich
ändern und zwar wie ihr wisst nicht mehr
der fan davon keine lange folge sondern
eher so ein paar kurze knackige wo man
auch echt an dran bleiben möchte
allerdings haben wir viel in die
kommentare geschrieben ja lass doch mal
ungekannte aber ich habe mir einfach
gedacht freunde
das ganze ist mein projekt und ich finde
natürlich dürfte auch mitbestimmen auf
einem kanal
aber die man den meisten hat es gefallen
das habe ich eine bewertung gesehen mit
dem schneiden und ich schneide jetzt
auch nicht so viel also die meisten
sachen lasse ich hab wirklich umgekehrt
wenn ich jetzt einfach mal so im
redefluss bin nur halt wenn dann
irgendwie gerade halt ich sehe dass ich
jetzt hier in frame einbruch ab oder so
was man meinen pc halten noch nicht da
ist und dann schneidet halt ein bisschen
aber ich schneide jetzt auch nicht alle
34 sekunden die ich jetzt hier dem
projekt verbringe und was auch bemängelt
wurde war dass ich erst so spät
angefangen habe über die themen zu reden
die mir zu gesendet wurden auf tour
und da habe ich übrigens auch letztens
also gestern wieder gefragt ja ob ihr
ein paar themen habt die ich über die
ich eventuell mal reden könnte und ich
mache ganz nebenbei übrigens dass ich
ein bisschen mehr holz am start habe und
ich brauche habe ich nicht doch ich
hatte da noch mehr knochen oder ich noch
voll viele skelette auch gesehen die ich
doch dann oder gar keine splatter
gesehen und umgebracht naja jedenfalls
würde ich sagen wir fangen an mit dem
ersten thema was mir zu gesendet wurde
von mikro und zwar schreibt der herr
stephan luca was wünscht du dir
eigentlich zu weihnachten es ist
natürlich wieder so die standardfrage
eigentlich zu weihnachten deswegen habe
ich die jetzt direkt noch an
angenommen ich wünsche mir eigentlich
recht wenig weil ich habe mir echt
nachgedacht letztes jahr war es so also
ich fange mal so an und zwar ist es halt
so dass wenn man ein kind ist wenn man
also ich bin ja auch selber irgendwie
noch ein kind wenn man aber also ich
weiß nicht 12 13 jahre alt ist dann muss
man halt noch für also bei mir was
damals so ich musste für eine
playstation 3 konsole musste ich zwei
jahre lang betteln und dann lag seemann
unterm weihnachtsbaum und dann war ich
mega happy
aber ich finde irgendwie wenn man jetzt
so ich bin ja schon ein bisschen älter
bin jetzt 18 und wohnen jetzt alleine
und dann ist es echt wirklich so man
kann sich aussuchen
man kann selbst sagen ja komm ich möchte
eine playstation an griechenland und
kaufe meine playstation sohn etwa und
gerade deswegen dass weihnachten für
ältere leute finde ich muss auch
erzählen 45 67 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
ich muss noch einer weswegen sich das
weihnachten für so etwas ältere leute
auch was heißt ältere leute aller luca
mann ich bin i will acht seen und
bezeichne mich als ältere person
mein gott was los mit mir auch mal eben
dahin noch mal in den birkenwald und
nehme auf dem weg auch alle bäume mit
weil hier in dem eis bikes biom ist es
einfach mega schwer an kohle
es ist einfach mega schweren
irgendwelche bäume zu kommen also was
ich sagen wollte ich denke dass das
weihnachtsfest gerade für jüngere leute
interessanter ist weil die sich halt
diese ganze sache die sie sich zu
weihnachten wünschen so im laden
entweder nicht kaufen dürfen oder es ist
zu teuer weil man halt noch nicht
eigenes geld verdient und ich hab jetzt
zum beispiel das glück dass ich mit
youtube schon ganz guten nicht job
gefunden habe ich studiere ja auch
nebenbei aber schon mal was gutes so
einfach so nebenbei gefunden womit ich
mir ein paar dinge im leben eventuell
finanzieren kann und
gerade deshalb finde ich das weiße
werden wenn ich habe eigentlich keine
richtigen wünschen weil wenn ich einen
wunsch habe und ich mir denke ok kommen
das ist so ein wunsch den möchte ich mir
schon immer mal erfüllt haben irgendwie
sowas wie die kamera oder irgendwie hier
eine playstation 4 mit fifa 15 oder
sowas dann geh ich halt einen laden und
im spa bisschen und gedern im laden
kaufen das und gerade deswegen finde ich
dass weihnachten er so auf jüngere leute
ganz interessant weg aber jetzt zurück
zur frage was ich mir eigentlich wünsche
dass wir viel zu viel platz und zwar ist
da oben noch einen holzblock her komm
her
ich wünsche mir eigentlich also ich hab
mir das recht lange überlegt weil
letztes jahr war es bei mir so dass ich
gedacht habe was wünsche ich mir dann
eigentlich zwei nacht eigentlich habe
ich gar keinen richtigen wünsche und
deswegen habe ich mir dieses jahr ist
schon vor ein paar tagen immer mal so
ein paar dinge aufgeschrieben die ich
unbedingt machen wollte und zwar ist
dabei dass ich mir auf jeden fall mal
eine gopro holen wollte weil ich übelst
keine schiefer und ich fahre über
weihnachten ski und wir sind in so einem
wellness-hotel mit meiner familie
irgendwo in österreich und dann wollte
ich da auch so ein paar sachen filmen
und mit der go pro land so unter wasser
und alles und das wird bestimmt richtig
richtig cool und deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht ein go pro wäre vielleicht ganz
cool
dann wünsche ich mir assassin's creed
was ich einfach ja ich weiss nicht in
totaler assassin's creed fans und das
würde ich halt auf jeden fall gerne
anzocken
und dann was ich mir auch schon immer
mal holen wollte war einfach ein
also ich liebe instagram und ich liebe
leute die gute instagram fotos machen
und das macht in deutschland für mich
nahezu niemand also wirklich so gute
fotografien und zwar wenn irgendwie ich
liebe symmetrie und wenn dann irgendwie
ich weiß nicht in amsterdam der nämlich
in amsterdam über das in bern oder in
wien
der u bahnhof bis zum beispiel komplette
rund und er sieht auf jeder seite gleich
aus sondern habe ich davon letztens ein
foto gesehen das war nicht extrem cool
habe ich mir ausgedruckt dann habe ich
fotos gesehen wo ich weiß nicht auch
einfach so sachen irgendwie eine
amerikanische
ein amerikanischer highway beim
sonnenaufgang oder so was ich finde man
kann eine extrem coole sachen aus fotos
rausholen wenn man sie einfach richtig
bearbeitet und sollen deswegen wünsche
ich mir eine go pro assassin's creed und
so eine riesige fotoleinwand mit den
besten instagram bildern die ich
irgendwie gesehen habe weil ich nicht
schon wieder wir sind hier bei sieben
minuten und ich habe es ja wieder ist
eine frage beantwortet aber na ja wir
machen wir weiter
würdest du lieber mit familie oder
freunden weihnachten feiern fragt sie
und zwar würde ich am liebsten wirklich
ich würde echt sagen mit familie weil
mit freunden also ich wohne jetzt
alleine und da macht man dazu jeden tag
irgendwie was mit freunden und verbringt
die zeit zusammen und in der uni und
alles mögliche aber mit der familie die
sieht man halt echt selten deswegen
denke ich mir weihnachten muss
eigentlich mit der familie verbracht
werden weil ich habe meine familie
beispielsweise auch wieder drei wochen
nicht gesehen und ich finde einfach
weihnachten muss mit der familie
verbracht werden ich meine freunde kann
man immer irgendwie treffen aber familie
kommen meistens noch weihnachten
zusammen vor allem weil es bei mir auch
so ist dass teile meiner familie ich
gegen stuttgart wohnen oder irgendwie so
und deswegen ist es ganz schön und man
trifft sich dann und das muss man auf
jeden fall mit der familie verbringen
was würdet ihr eigentlich davon halten
wenn wir mal alles hierhin bringen
würden
hier ist es irgendwie viel schöner als
er in unserem 1 billion weiterhin ein
ice bei kion da ist zwar eis und alles
aber hier kann man irgendwie hier sind
das gebäude und bessere landschaft und
so ich glaube ich hole das einfach mal
alles hierüber ist mein übrigens auch
viele dass es eventuell cooler wäre wenn
ich das ganze in dem creative mode bauen
würde hier alles mögliche aber ich finde
jetzt habe ich den crafting table wieder
des magnetischen wieder neuen rating buy
ich finde irgendwie ich meine wir hatten
die letzten jahre immer im creative oder
das vorletzte jahr nicht sind eigentlich
besser wenn wir das ganze mal im gaylord
0 machen dass das ganze quasi mir selbst
aufbauen und erarbeiten muss was sich
hier quasi mache und ich laufe jetzt mal
eben zurück bevor die nacht anbricht und
wie lange dauert noch bis zum 8 die
kommt sofort die kommen zu wort und hole
mir eben dann schnell meine kisten von
der hinten
irgendwo war das ja da hinten aber auf
jeden fall mit der familie
nächste frage kommt von peter bis 230
hast du zu weihnachten einen christbaum
die ich schon gesagt habe über
weihnachten vom 21 bis 28 in österreich
und werde da halt nicht zu hause seien
hier in meiner wohnung habe ich eh kein
weihnachtsbaum weil ich weiss nicht
bringt nichts wenn ich mit meiner form
ohne den ihre einstellung und ich bin
ich zu hause und danach werde ich nie
wieder wegpacken also das bringt nichts
wenn ich über weihnachten hier zu hause
wäre würde ich mir denke ich schon
weihnachtsbaum holen zum kleinen
zumindest aber wir meine familie wohnt
ja in bielefeld und da haben wir einen
weihnachtsbaum
und ja wir sind halt über weihnachten in
österreich das heißt also ich denke ich
also ich habe hier keinen weihnachtsbaum
meine familie hatte einen aber davon hab
ich ja herzlich wenig weil ich ja hier
in hamburg wohnen aber dass ich doch das
beantworte die frage ich selber hab
keinen weihnachtsbaum aber meine familie
mimi django fragt willst du mal heiraten
die frage ob jetzt angenommen weil das
eine frage ist die mit weihnachten
eigentlich nichts zu tun habe aber mit
liebe und weihnachten ist das fest der
liebe manchmal die frage ja ich möchte
irgendwann heiraten aber ich möchte mich
nicht so früh binden also es gibt ja
diesen wie heißt er ist ob pietro
lombardi oder irgendwie so der hat ja
mit 22 21 22 oder so hat er jetzt alle
anderen mädchen zur frau genommen die er
in der castingshow dsds kennen gelernt
habe davon halte ich ja recht wenig weil
ich weiß nicht was das soll natürlich
wenn ihr direkt gesehen haben okay wir
gehören zusammen und alles und blau und
die kennen sich halt ein zwei jahre und
so dann ist es ja deren sache ist es
allgemein deren sache ob sie heiraten
oder nicht aber ich denke mir eher so ja
ich weiss nicht passendes alter um zu
heiraten ist 30 35 finde ich aber ja ich
möchte auf unbedingt auf jeden fall mal
heiraten weil das einfach weil sie nicht
ich weiß nicht warum also ich weiß
ich glaube ich muss ja auch keinen grund
denn ich möchte dass und politik
schreibt worauf freust du dich an
weihnachten am meisten auf die geschenke
oder auf das essen mit der familie
hashtag fries das ist eine ganz gute
frage es gar nicht was ich pack' die
beiden kräfte aufpassen die nicht mal so
zusammen mit crafting table ich setze
jetzt einfach mal so untereinander dann
sieht das feld ich habe ihn genauso
hingesetzt wie den anderen auch
was ist denn los mit denen er gut dann
stehen sie jetzt halt so beieinander ist
mir egal ich freue mich sehr
cri cri cri cri cri
ja er ist tot ich freue mich ich weiß
nicht so oft beides also dieses jahr
freue ich mich irgendwie vielmehr auf
das essen weil wir halt im hotel sind
und sondern das essen immer ganz geil
und alles mögliche aber ich denke dass
ich mich
es kommt halt drauf an also ich weiß
nicht wie meine eltern das machen wenn
er so ich glaube nicht mehr an den
weihnachtsmann bevor das jetzt irgendwie
denkt weil ich halt schon wünsche sage
aber ich weiß auch gar nicht wie man das
machen wenn diese geschenke für meine
schwester nicht mitnehmen
ist auch egal jedenfalls ich muss auch
gucken wie ich das mit video produktion
mache aber ich freue mich auf jeden fall
auch beides natürlich auch auf die auf
die geschenke aber es ist jetzt nicht so
dass wenn alle da ein etwas liegt wenn
da nicht das liegt was ich mir gewünscht
dass dann sage kein bock und so jetzt
hier noch weiter hier zu sein und so
total akku bin sondern es geht halt
einfach darum dass wenn ich das ganze
hier quasi wenn ich etwas geschenkt wenn
ich nicht das geschenk bekomme was ich
mir wünsche dann dann kaufe ich mir
quasi so nach weihnachten in etwa habe
ich ja vorhin schon gesagt dass man
damit 18 einfach sagen kann ja dann
kaufe ich mir das halt selber und so
aber ich weiß nicht ich freue mich
irgendwie auf beide ist auf alles an
weihnachten irgendwie gerade weil wir
halt wegfahren und weil ich auch lust
auf schneefall schnee frost auf
skifahren habe und vor allem auch
einfach auf die tatsache dass
hoffentlich in österreich schnee liegen
wird weil ich weiss nicht weihnachten
ohne schnee ist so wie spaghetti
bolognese soße
das geht für mich einfach nicht wahr
dass wird das wetter dann natürlich
zeigen aber ich denke ich freue mich
einfach auf alle sachen rund um
weihnachten und das war jetzt auch schon
die letzte frage ihr denkt
wahrscheinlich
das waren auch erst fünf fragen das
waren erst fünf fragen aber ich habe mir
gedacht da in der letzten folge die
gegen jahr 22 oder 23 minuten
da haben wir extrem lange für die ganzen
fragen gebraucht deswegen habe ich mir
diesmal jetzt gedacht okay dann nehme
ich halt nur fünf fragen ist vielleicht
auch ganz gut dann kann ich mich auf
diese fünf fragen besser konzentrieren
und reiter nicht die ganzen fragen
nacheinander durch und dann kommen wir
auch endlich bei dieser video länge an
die ich angestrebt habe muss man ganz
kurz ab ziemlich das mache 12345 sie ja
schon falsche hier muss nämlich noch mal
so ein bisschen
erde hin so dann zähle ich mal hier
nochmal das müsste jetzt stemme man 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 und dann kommt hier noch ein
ich hab noch keinen genauen plan wie das
ganze aussehen wird aber mal schaut also
ihr wisst ich bin nicht so der der
geilste bauer crazy aktion norm hier in
stein zu setzen bruder und jetzt hab ich
hier über auf den anderen block und
setzt sich jetzt noch einsteigen und
barmen
und da ist das schon ein neuer kanal
also ihr wisst ich bin nicht so ganz der
geilste minecraft bauer
aber ich weiß auch nicht was das hier am
ende werden soll
aber ich versuche halt einfach so ein
bisschen was zu bauen und das
weihnachtlich zu gestalten und das ganze
halt im game 1 0 und ich hoffe euch
gefällt das einfach nachher bisher haben
wir das ganze so hier aufgebaut und du
da oben kommt schmeckt das wird dann so
in etwa das haus nach ich hoffe das wird
irgendwie nach was aussehen
das sieht bisher nämlich noch so ein
bisschen das ganze noch so ein bisschen
crazy aus nicht weiß auch ich wollte
noch irgendwas sagen
irgendwas wichtiges na ja ich würde auf
jeden fall sagen freunde das war's mit
der zweiten folge tourismus braucht wir
haben in dieser folge geschafft dass ihr
von hinten
hierhin umgezogen sind ich habe ein
bisschen kohle gold im standard ipv6
kohle
irgendwann werden wir auch eine höhle
gehen und ein bisschen spaß haben aber
ich möchte jetzt erstmal das haus noch
so ein bisschen bauen dass das irgendwie
nach was aussieht mal schauen so zeit
sieht er eher mager und kacke aus aber
das wird die zeit denke schon regeln
und ich habe wieder fünf fragen
beantwortet wenn ihr weitere christmas
frage weihnachtliche fragen die mit
weiter etwas zu tun haben einfach mir
auf twitter folgen twitter.com
schrägstrich contractor unter fragen
schreiben unter den hashtag fragt luca
dann kommt eventuell in der nächsten
folge dran wenn es euch gefallen habe
ich mich über eine bewertung freuen und
ich hoffe euch hat auch gefallen dass
ich hier so schnell jetzt ein bisschen
eingefügt habe und mit dem christmas
rahmen um ein gesicht rum und ich hoffe
einfach euch gefällt